la siguiente información muestra la
mediana del ingreso anual de una familia
desde 1995 al 2002
haz la gráfica dispersa de esta
información y encuentra la ecuación cuál
será la mediana del ingreso esperado de
esta familia para el año 2010 que
representan la pendiente y la
intersección con en este problema aquí
lo que quiero mostrarles es cómo
acomodar datos en una línea y en lugar
de usar mi tableta de dibujo como en los
demás vídeos voy a escribir directo en
excel y si tienen este programa podrán
resolver este problema ustedes también
lo que quiero que comprendan es el
significado de acomodar datos en una
línea o en una regresión lineal aquí nos
dicen que esos datos son la mediana del
ingreso de una familia recuerden que
mediana se refiere al valor de enmedio
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
poner esa información en una manera que
excel a entienda tenemos el año la
mediana del ingreso que está puesta como
ingreso aquí voy a poner una columna que
sea años
y 1995 y como comenzamos desde 1995 mi
primer dato va a ser cero y los
siguientes van a ser consecutivos aquí
lleno en serie y tengo que son desde el
1995 hasta el 2002 siete años y voy a
copiar la información que tengo aquí que
ya está escrita sobre la mediana de los
ingresos de la familia le pongo aquí y
aquí escribo ingresos verán que en excel
es muy fácil graficar esa información y
también crear una regresión de dicha
información sin saber dónde hacer clic
lo que debemos hacer es seleccionar toda
la información y vamos a insertar una
gráfica dispersa o de dispersión de
hecho aquí nos da la explicación de qué
se tratan estas gráficas inserta un
gráfico de dispersión también conocido
como gráfico xy este tipo de gráfico
compara pares de valores vamos a elegir
este que nada más tiene los puntitos
dispersos
le damos clic y aquí nos presenta esta
información la voy a agrandar para que
pueda notar la mejor tenemos los datos
del año cero aquí en el eje x hasta el
año 8 que yo tengo del 0 al 7 y tengo el
ingreso y cada uno de estos puntos es la
información que yo tengo aquí el primer
punto es el año 0 y el ingreso fue de 53
mil 807 aquí lo vemos 0 53 mil 807 muy
bien aquí con esto ya gráfica mos estos
datos pero también nos están pidiendo la
ecuación bueno ya que tenemos esto voy a
irme aquí arriba a ver qué tipo de
diseños de gráfico hay aquí hay varios
pero estoy buscando uno donde se vea una
línea y además se tenga una fx o una
función aquí está
le doy clic y como ven me modificó el
gráfico y esto es los datos que tenía
originalmente pero aquí me agregó esta
línea y además me está mostrando la
ecuación de esta línea que vamos a
agrandarlo o que creo que con esto se
alcanza a ver mejor
tenemos que la ecuación de esta línea es
igual a 1882 punto 3x más 52 1847
recordemos lo que sabemos sobre la
pendiente y la intersección en la
intersección en
es cuando está x vale cero por lo tanto
todo esto va a valer cero mi interés
acción en 52 mil 847 que si usamos esta
línea como nuestra medida a nuestro
modelo aquí vamos a encontrar la
intersección en ya en este punto que
está un poquito por debajo de nuestro
primer valor que tenemos en esta etapa
nuestro valor era de 53 mil 807 y esa
intersección es 52 mil 847 así que aquí
el significado de la intersección en
jeff es donde esta línea intersecta con
el año 0 o 1995 siguiendo esta línea nos
indicaría que el ingreso en 1995 fue de
52 mil 847 aunque como les comentaba los
datos reales son un poco diferentes pero
lo que queremos aquí es una línea que
esté lo más cerca que se pueda
todos los puntos de la información en la
gráfica trata de minimizar el cuadrado
de la distancia a cada punto
ahora vamos a usar esta bonita ecuación
para hacer predicciones ya que es un
buen modelo de la información que
tenemos y trataremos de responder
nuestras preguntas cuanto esperamos que
sea el ingreso mediano de la familia
para el año 2010
bueno aquí solo tenemos que usar esta
ecuación que nos dieron en la que el
último año fue 2002 y vamos a ver cuánto
falta para el 2010 estoy aquí del 2002 y
quiero agregar valores en serie que me
falta 2006
aquí está 2010 me faltan vamos a
agrandar esto también que sea en serie y
tenemos que el año 2010 es el año 15 a
partir de 1995 tomaremos este dato y lo
vamos a sustituir en esta fórmula de
manera que voy a escribir esta ecuación
en otra celda esto va a ser igual
1882 punto 3 por nuestro año que es 15
más 52 mil 847 damos center y nos da
este valor de 81.000 81.5 si
continuáramos esta línea todo el tiempo
necesario hasta llegar al año 2010 se
cruzaría con el valor de 81 mil 81.5
espero que hayan encontrado interesante
esto las hojas de cálculo son
herramientas muy útiles para manipular
información y espero que les haya dado
un sentido del por qué los modelos
lineales son interesantes así como las
líneas lo son y cómo podemos interpretar
esta información para extrapolar algún
tipo de predicción como lo hicimos aquí
usando esta regresión lineal